>> Judge Jeanine: THE BIDEN
WHITE HOUSE FACING FRESH
ACCUSATIONS OF COLLUDING WITH
BIG TECH TO CENSOR AMERICANS.
A NEW LAWSUIT FILED BY TWO
REPUBLICAN ATTORNEYS GENERAL IS
PUSHING FOR THE RELEASE OF MORE
EMAILS BETWEEN TOP BIDEN
OFFICIALS AND BIG TECH TITANS
AFTER GETTING THEIR HANDS ON
TALKS THAT SHED LIGHT ON THEIR
COZY RELATIONSHIP.
THEY SAY THE EVIDENCE IS
APPALLING.
>> WE KNOW IT IS AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT, BUT WE
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW HIGH AND
HOW WIDE THIS GOES BECAUSE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
OBJECTING TO THE DISCOVERY OF
THE FOLKS FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
THEY ARE CLAIMING EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, WHICH IS NONSENSE
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT ASKING FOR
INTERNAL COMMUNICATIONS.
WE ARE ASKING FOR COMMUNICATIONS
WITH THE THIRD PARTY.
THIS OUGHT TO SHOCK EVERY
AMERICAN.
THE GOVERNMENT IS ACTUALLY
CENSORING AND SILENCING
AMERICANS.
>> Judge Jeanine: OKAY, SO
WHAT WE HAVE GOT IS WHAT WE'VE
ALWAYS SUSPECTED, KAYLEIGH, AND
THAT IS THE WHITE HOUSE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
COLLUDING WITH BIG
TECH, FACEBOOK AND TWITTER, AND
BASICALLY TELLING THEM WHAT THEY
SHOULD SUPPRESS AND NOT
SUPPRESS.
THE QUESTION IS, DOES THE
WHITE HOUSE HAVE THAT RIGHT?
>> Kayleigh: NO, COURSE THEY
DON'T AND IT IS ILLEGAL BECAUSE
YOU CANNOT SUPPRESS
FIRST AMENDMENT SPEECH HE SAID
SOME OF THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT AND EVEN SUBSIDIARY.
THE DISINFORMATION BOARD, THAT
DIDN'T HAPPEN APPEARS TO HAVE
HAPPEN IN PRACTICE WHEN YOU HAVE
45 FEDERAL OFFICIALS WHO ENGAGED
IN THIS ACCORDING TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
11 AGENCIES.
THAT IS A BIG OPERATION.
WE KNEW THIS JEN PSAKI TOLD US
JULY 15 WITH FACEBOOK POST AND
SPREAD OF THIS INFORMATION WAS A
PRIORITY.
SO THEY HAD MET OUT LOUD.
WHAT IS STRIKING TO ME BECAUSE
WE KNEW THIS WAS HAPPENING IN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S THIRD
PARTIES WHO WILLINGLY ENGAGE.
WHEN YOU HAVE A FACEBOOK
OFFICIAL EMAIL THE SURGEON
GENERAL AND SAY, "I KNOW OUR
TEAM IS BACK TODAY TO A BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE SCOPE OF WHAT THE
WHITE HOUSE EXPECTS FROM US."
YOU MEMBER BRIAN SELTZER SAID TO
JEN PSAKI HOW CAN WE BE BETTER?
SOCIAL MEDIA, WHAT DO YOU EXPECT
FROM US AND BIG MEDIA HOW CAN WE
PUT BATTER?
QUESTION MARKET IS IT
PRIVATE SECTOR PARTNERING WITH
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> >> Judge Jeanine: JOEY, ONE
OF THE THINGS SO DISTURBING
JEN PSAKI AS KAYLEIGH SAID
FLANKING WHAT IS A PROBLEMATIC
POST WHICH IS BASICALLY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BEING A
CENSORSHIP ENTERPRISE, A
VIOLATION AS KAYLEIGH SAYS AS
THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
WHERE DID THEY GET UP DOING
THIS?
>> Joey: THEY DON'T HAVE MUCH
OBJECTIVITY.
THEY ARE NOT TRYING TO HIDE IT
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE IT IS
RIGHTEOUS, HOLY, TRUTH.
IN THEIR MINDS WE DIDN'T GET TO
DECIDE WHAT WAS GOOD OR NOT GOOD
FOR OUR BODIES.
THEY DID APPEAR THEY WOULD HAVE
FLAGGED A POST ABOUT MASTERLY ON
IF THEY HAD HAD THIS TYPE OF
COORDINATION GOING ON EARLY ON R
MAYBE THEY HAD BEEN IN CHARGE T.
THEY WOULD HAVE LED POST THAT
SAY MASKS ONLY WORK AND THEN SIX
MONTHS LATER, FAUCI SAYS
SOMETHING TO THAT EFFECT AND ALL
OF ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY WOULD
HAVE BEEN STEPPING ALL OVER
THEMSELVES WITH THE WHITE HOUSE
OF THIS PANDEMIC.
SO AS THINGS CHANGE AND NEW
INFORMATION COMES OUT, THEY HAVE
TO ACCEPT THAT THEY GOT IT EARLY
ON EVEN IF NO ILL INTENT WAS
ILL-ADVISED AND THEY WERE
SQUASHING PEOPLE WHO WENT OUT
INTO THE WRONG RESEARCH.
FOUND THEIR OWN ANSWERS AND JUST
PUT IT OUT THERE AND TO
SAY, "YOU DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT
TO DO THAT."
WHEN IT COMES TO THE
FIRST AMENDMENT BUT THEY WON'T
TRY TO HIDE IT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T CARE.
THEY BELIEVE THEY ARE RIGHTEOUS
IN DOING THIS AND THEY BELIEVE
IN THEIR POWER MORE THAN OUR
RIGHTS.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW THE
DISINFORMATION BOARD BOARD THAT
THEY FLOATED AND SOLD TO AMERICA
WASN'T GOING TO ACCEPT IT IS
REALLY IN FACT ALTHOUGH THEY
DON'T HAVE IT OUT OPENLY WITH
WHAT'S HER NAME SINGING
MARY POPPINS.
BUT THEY BASICALLY HAVE
DISINFORMATION BOARD.
DO YOU THINK THAT HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL, JESSICA?
>> Jessica: I'M NOT SURE, THE
COURTS WILL DO THAT -- I'M NOT A
LAWYER AND I DON'T WANT TO
PRETEND TO BE ONE.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW
ABOUT THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
>> Jessica: YES, I DO KNOW
I DO KNOW THERE ARE CONCERNS A
COMPANY WOULD TAKE TO MAKE SURE
THEY ARE PROTECTING PEOPLE ON
THERE ESPECIALLY SOMETHING LIKE
MEDICAL INFORMATION.
I WILL SAY, JOEY, ACTUALLY
REALITY WAS ACCORDING TO
FACEBOOK, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WAS COORDINATING
WITH THEM WHEN COVID STARTED.
THIS WAS NOT JUST A DEMOCRAT.
>> Kayleigh: NO, IT WAS MY
DESK.
>> Jessica: EARLY ON.
>> Judge Jeanine: WARE, CNN?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jessica: ANYWAY, SO I WAS
PREGNANT DURING THE PANDEMIC ONE
OF THE MAIN PIECES HAVE
DISINFORMATION GOING AROUND IS
THAT GOT VACCINATED DURING
PREGNANCY, YOU ARE HIGHLY LIKELY
OF MISCARRYING.
THAT WAS UTTERLY SCARING.
I ENDED UP GETTING VACCINATED
WHILE I WAS PREGNANT AND MY
DOCTOR ASSURED ME EVERYTHING WAS
FINE.
MAKING SURE INFORMATION LIKE
THAT IS NOT GETTING OUT THERE IS
A WORTHY CAUSE.
AND I'M NOT FOR CENSORSHIP.
I AM CAREFUL LOOKING AT THESE
KINDS OF THINGS BECAUSE THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE GETTING THAT
INFORMATION OVER SOCIAL MEDIA.
WHETHER IT IS THEY WOULD HAVE
CARED ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN'S
LAPTOP, I CARE A LOT LESS ABOUT
THAT THEN INFORMATION ABOUT
MEDICINES THAT CAN HELP SAVE OUR
LIVES OR PASS IMMUNITY ONTO THE
BABIES.
MY DAUGHTER WAS BORN WITH
ANTIBODIES BECAUSE I GOT
VACCINATED.
>> Judge Jeanine: GREG, HOW
ABOUT THE FACT THAT SOME OF THE
STUFF THEY WERE TELLING US
DURING THE PANDEMIC TURNED OUT
TO BE ABSOLUTELY NOT SUPPORTED,
NOT TRUE, NOT ACCURATE, AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN THEY WANT TO SAY TO
US, "WE STILL NEED TO BE IN
CHARGE OF WHAT YOU DO AND DON'T
DO."
SHOULDN'T IT BE BETWEEN YOU AND
YOUR DOCTOR?
IN THE INTRODUCTORY TO FIGURE
THIS OUT, THAT IS THE RISK THEY
TAKE.
>> Greg: THE BIG POINT IS FOR
A BUDDY IN THE WAY HE MULLIKEN
WHEN YOU HAVE A PANDEMIC EVERY
ONCE 100 YEARS.
PEOPLE WILL BEAT HIM INITIALLY
BE RIGHT AND WRONG AND THAT WILL
CHANGE.
I AM BROKE DISINFORMATION.
BECAUSE ONE MAN'S DISINFORMATION
IS ANOTHER PERSON'S FACT, RIGHT?
A SENSOR NEVER SAYS THEY ARE A
SENSOR.
THEY JUST SAY THEY ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT YOUR HEALTH.
SO THEY USE MEDICAL INFORMATION
NOW HAS KIND OF THE WEAPONRY TO
START CURTAILING INFORMATION.
SO DISINFORMATION HAS NOW BECOME
THE NEW GATE SPEECH.
AND HELP AS A SHIELD LIKE
EVERYTHING IS A HEALTH PROBLEM
HERE IS LIKE LANGUAGE COULD BE A
HEALTH PROBLEM.
THE LANGUAGE THAT YOU USE COULD
BE HURTFUL, AND THAT IS A WHOLE
PROBLEM.
THEY CAN SAY ANY QUALITY OR LACK
OF EQUITY AS A HEALTH PROBLEM.
SO YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL TO
PLAY THIS GAME.
IT IS ALL ABOUT CONTROLLING THE
MICROPHONE.
WE'LL RENT THE LEFT SEES
SOCIAL MEDIA AS AN EXTENSION OF
THE MEDIA,  A PLATFORM WHERE
THEY CAN MANIPULATE THE SPIN ON
THE PROPAGANDA, TURN IT ON, TURN
IT OFF AND THEY FEEL ENTITLED
BECAUSE GOING BACK TO THE A
BLOCK THE OTHER SIDE IS EVIL AND
THEREFORE SHOULD NOT HAVE THE
SAME RIGHTS THEY DO BECAUSE
EVERYTHING I'M GOING TO SAY IS
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO BE
DISINFORMATION, RIGHT?
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT DISAGREE
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE DID NOT GET
VACCINATED.
AND YOU CAN'T ARGUE -- AND THEY
WILL BE VERY POLITE TO YOU ABOUT
IT.
YOU CAN'T SAY LIKE YOU SHOULD
HAVE GOT THAT INFORMATION.
THE SOLUTION TO MISINFORMATION
IS ALWAYS MORE INFORMATION, NOT
LESS.
>> Jessica: I WANT TO SAY AND
I THINK THIS IS TRUE OF A LOT OF
POLITICAL DEBATES, ESPECIALLY
INITIAL LIKE ABORTION.
I HAVE ALWAYS FELT THIS WAY.
NO ONE IS RIGHT OR WRONG
NECESSARILY.
IT IS ABOUT LEGALITIES AND
PROTECTIONS ARE.
I NEVER TOLD A WOMAN, YOU HAVE
GOT TO GET VACCINATED RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS YOUR BODY, YOUR
CHOICE, ABSOLUTELY.
BUT I DON'T THINK THE SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO CIRCULATE ABOUT
MISCARRIAGES THAT WERE NOT
HAPPENING.
>> Judge Jeanine: HOW DO YOU
POLICE THAT REALLY?
>> Greg: THAT INFORMATION -- I
GET IT IF SOMEBODY SAYS IT IS
PERFECTLY LEGAL TO SET FIRE BUT
THAT BAD INFORMATION AND YOU
COULD GET CHARGED FOR TELLING A
CHILD IN A LINE OF FIRE.
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT HIS
OBJECTIVE AS SOCIETY, THESE LAWS
HAVE TO BE FOLLOWED AND IF YOU
VIOLATE THEM YOU VIOLATE A
SOCIAL CONTRACT.
>> Joey: THERE IS A PARTY OF A
STORY BURIED BECAUSE
SOCIAL MEDIA, IT WAS THE FBI,
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES CREATED
THIS BUBBLE THAT WE LIVE IN
AND WE ONLY GET IT CERTAIN TYPE
OF INFORMATION BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT WE WANT AND
THEY KEEP US ADDICTED TO OPENING
THIS PHONE.
SO THEY HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THEIR OWN SINS AND THIS BEFORE
THEY CAN PUMP TO IT
ADMINISTRATION ON CENSORING.
THEY ARE CENSORING US BEFORE THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS A CHANCE TO.
>> Judge Jeanine: UP NEXT TO
AMERICA'S NEVER ENDING TRAVEL
NIGH